تصريح جديد للرئيس الاوكراني فولو دي
ميرسي يقول فيه انه لا يعرف ما حدث في
بولندا بعد سقوط صاروخ اكد حينها ان مصدره
موسكو
لا اعرف ما حدث والعالم لا يعرف ايضا انا
على يقين انه كان صاروخا روسيا ومتاكد
ايضا من اننا اطلقنا النار من انظمه
للدفاع الجوي من المستحيل قول اي شيء محدد
اليوم ولا نستخلص النتائج الا بعد التحقيق
في الشمال الاطلس واشنطن رجحوا فرضيه ان
صاروخ دفاع جوي اوكراني سقط بالخطا في
بولندا العضو في الحلف راي يتفق معه
الرئيس البولندي لا ينبغي ان يفاجئكم ذلك
الناس تحت تاثير العاطفه تخيلوا مشاعر
الرئيس الاوكراني انه متاثر جدا بما يمر
به شعبه روسي اطلقت المئات من الصواريخ
على اوكرانيا واوكرانيا دافعت عن نفسها
وفي خضم هذه العمليه حدث ما حدث
بطلب من الرئيس جيلنسكي وصل خبراء
اوكرانيون الى موقع انفجار لتحقيق في
مصدره من جهته اعلى وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي انطوني بنكن انه بغض النظر عن
نتيجه التحقيق تتحمل روسيا المسؤوليه
الكامله عن الحادث